con esa primera invitada del día
hablamos de Perú donde ayer se desató
una nueva crisis de gobierno tras la
destitución y detención de en que fuera
el presidente Pedro Castillo logra que
este ordenara la disolución del Congreso
que se preparaba para votar una moción
de destitución contra él contra el que
fuera el mandatario Dina boluarte es
ahora la nueva presidenta del país la
séptima jefa de estado desde el año 2016
saludamos entonces a nuestro primer
invitadayas Milagros Campos analista
política y profesora de derecho
constitucional y derecho parlamentario
en la pontificia Universidad Católica y
en la universidad San Martín de porrese
Gracias Milagros por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de jueves en directo América
de Francia 24 para analizar todo este
panorama de inestabilidad política que
vive Perú quisiera también que usted nos
dé pues luces de qué fue exactamente lo
que ocurrió ayer con esta orden de
disolución del Congreso por parte del
que fuera presidente Pedro Castillo
algunos dicen que fue un golpe de estado
otros dicen que fue un auto golpe que se
dio Castillo que no le salió como quería
que realmente pasó digamos para poner en
contexto a toda nuestra audiencia
internacional y entender un poco lo que
ocurre dentro de la política peruana
Buenos días Raúl y amigos France la
verdad es que lo que hemos tenido es sin
ningún adjetivo un golpe de estado bajo
la modalidad del autogolpe mulando lo
que ocurrió en 1992 pues no solamente se
anunció la disolución del Congreso sino
también la intervención del Sistema
Nacional de Justicia esto convertía
claramente a Pedro Castillo en un
autócrata Y pues la decisión no resistió
más que pocos minutos porque no solo sus
ministros
alguna parte de ellos renunciaron sino
que lo más destacable es que de manera
contundente las distintas instituciones
constitucionalmente autónomas el propio
poder judicial
rechazaron inmediatamente
con un pronunciamiento
colectivo en en el caso de los de las
instituciones colegiadas y el congreso
hacia la una y media de la tarde declaró
su vacancia por permanente incapacidad
moral con ciento un votos cuando se
requerían ochenta y siete claramente las
denuncias por corrupción fueron
abrumadoras en este caso Eso no
significa Pues que
esto haya generado solamente un problema
de las inestabilidad porque
efectivamente Son seis presidentes en
seis años sino que claramente coloca al
Perú
que ha sido calificado como una
democracia defectuosa en una situación
que
defiende más bien los derechos
ciudadanos la democracia y claramente
Busca que quienes ejercen la más alta
magistratura pues tengan las
calificaciones éticas para hacerlo sí
Milagros aquí hay aquí hay dos cosas
paralizar sin duda alguna digamos de
alguna manera la fortaleza de las
instituciones peruanas que van más allá
del mandatario que está de turno Pero
también evidentemente toda esta crisis
política que ha vivido Perú desde 2016
con ahora Dina boluarte la séptima
presidenta en seis años que tanta
gobernabilidad puede tener Quien fuera
además a vicepresidenta de Pedro
Castillo sí la podría dejar gobernar el
congreso Cómo están las fuerzas dentro
del legislativo peruano para poder dejar
a a Volverte gobernar no y y pues parar
de alguna manera toda esta crisis
política porque al final afecta la
estabilidad del país la continuación de
varias políticas que me imagino que nos
han podido desarrollar por este cambio
de presidente continuo
Totalmente de acuerdo Raúl acá El Perú
enfrenta dos grandes retos el debina
boluarte porque es una presidenta en un
congreso muy fragmentado ella no tiene
partido ni bancada y Eso la hace
necesariamente a mirar hacia el congreso
un congreso que si bien tiene poca
aprobación es el que le va a dar la
gobernabilidad de inavaluarte Sin
embargo tiene también que mirar
políticas públicas y pues tratar de
buscar una agenda mínima y ciertos
consensos para una reforma política que
al menos establezca la eliminación de la
prohibición de reelección parlamentaria
inmediata y que apunte también hacia
regular un impeachment para evitar que
tengamos una cláusula tan abierta como
la permanente incapacidad moral que
requiere de 87 a todos y que ha sido una
amenaza constante después de que Pedro
Pablo kuczynski renunciara Al verse
expuesto a esta causal creo que nuestro
sistema que es un presidencialismo muy
parlamentarizado el más parlamentarizado
de la región tiene también retos en
tratar de hacer ciertos ajustes pero no
todos son reformas sino que depende
también del actuar de estas élites
políticas que son más bien inexpertas
porque como señalo en el Perú se
prohibió la reelección inmediata seguido
de una alta volatilidad y fragmentación
entre los partidos políticos Milagros
también me genera la duda esto Cómo se
traslada a la ciudadanía porque al final
también evidentemente ellos son los que
sienten toda inestabilidad de gobierno y
hacia dónde va el país no
en efecto El Perú en todas las los
índices que se hacen sobre democracia
está muy por debajo de los pares
latinoamericanos los peruanos tienen una
insatisfacción por la democracia
eso sin embargo no se ha traducido en
una posible aceptación de un golpe de
estado que ha sido rechazado también por
la población pero creo que el gran reto
de la clase política es en este momento
procurar un diálogo para buscar una
salida No ya a esta crisis puntual sino
a la búsqueda por gobernabilidad
democrática Milagros también antes de
finalizar Quisiera saber su opinión si
la nueva presidenta pudiera llegar hasta
2026 evidentemente estábamos conversando
que se tienen que dar un terreno en el
parlamento para que esto sucediera pero
dicen también otros analistas dentro de
Perú y Y cómo ve la política para la
gobernabilidad de quien es ahora la
nueva presidenta
el marco
supone que la señora boluarte gobierne
hasta el 2026 sin necesidad de convocar
a elecciones generales que es lo que
señala un sector de analistas y hay un
algunas propuestas ciudadanas en ese
sentido sin embargo creo que también es
necesario pensar que si Dina boluarte
forma un gabinete como lo ha anunciado
de ancha base esto le permitiría tener
un respaldo ilegitimidad para mantenerse
hasta el 2026 nadie quiere que pues esto
sea solo un gobierno de
transición y que afronte muy corto plazo
amenazas que generen una inestabilidad
porque efectivamente El Perú requiere de
políticas públicas que aporten brechas
entre los distintos territorios y
distintos peruanos que viven en zonas
más alejadas de las zonas propiamente
urbanas y creo que es imposible en un
escalamiento de conflicto entre
ejecutivo y legislativo que se atiendan
estas necesidades acaba de ser las
elecciones regionales y municipales y
también hay autoridades que se inician
en el próximo año y entonces creo que es
un buen momento para establecer
mecanismos de diálogo que permitan
llegar a ciertos acuerdos básicos y
consensos mínimos que atraviesan
necesariamente creo yo por algunas
reformas constitucionales puntuales